Add a pop of culture to every room in your house with SiriusXM. Stream over 425 channels of ad-free music, plus exclusive talk, world-class news, live play-by-play sports, comedy, and popular podcasts with the SXM app. Subscribe to the streaming platinum plan and get your first three months for free. Visit SiriusXM.ca for details.
使用 SiriusXM，让您的家中每个房间都充满文化气息。通过 SXM 应用程序流式传输超过 425 个无广告音乐频道、独家谈话节目、世界一流的新闻、现场体育赛事播报、喜剧和热门播客。订阅流媒体白金套餐，即可免费享受前三个月服务。详情请访问 SiriusXM.ca。
SiriusXM, everything you want to hear lives here. MUSIC Our episodes deal with SiriusXM and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website.
SiriusXM，您想听的一切都在这里。音乐 本期节目涉及 SiriusXM 以及往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关机密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用程序上或我们网站上的本期节目说明。
MUSIC Christy Marceau was abruptly awoken by the sharp ringing of her family's telephone. The 18-year-old had been sleeping in. It was 10 a.m. on Tuesday, September 6, 2011, and she didn't need to be anywhere that morning. Christy was nearing the end of her first year at New Zealand's Auckland University of Technology,
音乐 克里斯蒂·马索 (Christy Marceau) 被家里清脆的电话铃声突然惊醒。这位 18 岁的女孩一直在睡懒觉。那是 2011 年 9 月 6 日星期二上午 10 点，那天早上她不需要去任何地方。克里斯蒂即将读完新西兰奥克兰理工大学的第一年课程，
where she was studying events management. Her dream was to have her own events company by the age of 30. For now, she was still living in the family home where she'd grown up in the suburb of Hillcrest on the city's north shore. The phone stopped ringing before Christy could answer it. She hadn't gotten to it in time.
她当时在那里学习活动管理。她的梦想是在 30 岁时拥有自己的活动公司。目前，她仍然住在家里，也就是她从小长大的城市北岸希尔克雷斯特 (Hillcrest) 郊区。电话还没等克里斯蒂接听就停了。她没赶上接听。
But then, a few seconds later, it started ringing again. This time, Christy picked up the receiver and said, hello. A male voice on the other end asked to speak with her. This is Christy, she replied. It turned out that the caller was an acquaintance of hers named Akshay Chand. Up until recently, the pair had both worked
但几秒钟后，电话又响了起来。这一次，克里斯蒂拿起话筒说：“喂”。电话那头的一个男声要求和她通话。“我就是克里斯蒂，”她回答道。原来，打电话的人是她的一个熟人，名叫阿克谢·昌德 (Akshay Chand)。直到最近，两人都曾在
at the same local supermarket. They weren't close, but they were friendly, chatting during their shifts and sometimes talking outside of work via Facebook Messenger. They lived just a few blocks from one another, and Chand had been over to Christy's house on several occasions.
当地的同一家超市工作。他们虽然不是很亲密，但关系很好，在值班时会聊天，有时也会在下班后通过 Facebook Messenger 聊天。他们住得离彼此只有几个街区，昌德曾多次去过克里斯蒂家。
He often needed someone to speak with about his personal problems. Kind and open-hearted, Christy was always willing to listen. Christy knew that Chand had been struggling lately, but she couldn't have anticipated what he said next. Her heart sank, as he stated. I put 40 pills into a drink and I've crushed them all. And if you don't get to my house within 10 minutes,
他经常需要找人倾诉他的个人问题。克里斯蒂善良而又心胸开阔，总是愿意倾听。克里斯蒂知道昌德最近一直在苦苦挣扎，但她怎么也没有预料到他接下来会说的话。当他说出这句话时，她的心沉了下去：“我在饮料里放了 40 粒药丸，我都碾碎了。如果你在 10 分钟内不到我家，
I'm gonna drink them. Without hesitating, Christy headed over to help Chand. MUSIC Christy Marceau had been in such a rush after receiving Akshay Chand's call that she barely had time to get dressed. She hastily pulled on a pair of black tracksuit pants and a jumper over the blue top, bra,
我就把它们喝下去。”克里斯蒂没有犹豫，径直赶去帮助昌德。音乐 在接到阿克谢·昌德的电话后，克里斯蒂·马索匆忙得几乎没有时间穿衣服。她匆忙套上一条黑色运动裤和一件套头衫，套在里面睡觉时穿的蓝色上衣、
and bikini bottoms that she'd been sleeping in. Then she grabbed her keys and mobile phone, ran outside to her car, and drove the one-kilometre journey to Chand's home. It wasn't in Christy's nature to ignore a cry for help. She harboured a soft spot for those who found life more difficult. Once during high school, she'd noticed a younger boy standing all alone.
胸罩和比基尼泳裤外面。然后她抓起钥匙和手机，跑到车里，驱车一公里来到昌德的家。忽视求救信号不是克里斯蒂的性格。她对那些生活更加艰难的人心存怜悯。在高中时，她曾注意到一个男孩独自一人站着。
When Christy asked if he was all right, the boy told her he had no friends. Christy took it upon herself to introduce him to a group of students his age and helped him make conversation with them. The boy's mother later called the school to pass along her thanks to Christy. Her deep sense of compassion had also led Christy
当克里斯蒂问他是否还好时，男孩告诉她他没有朋友。克里斯蒂主动提出带他去认识一群同龄学生，并帮助他与他们对话。后来，男孩的母亲打电话给学校，向克里斯蒂表达谢意。她强烈的同情心也促使克里斯蒂
to volunteer for an animal welfare charity and organise fundraisers aimed at ending world hunger. She had a wide circle of friends from all walks of life that she socialised with often. Unlike Christy, Akshay Chand had a very small circle of friends. He was extremely intelligent but socially awkward, especially around women.
自愿为动物福利慈善机构工作，并组织旨在消除世界饥荒的筹款活动。她有着广泛的朋友圈，来自各行各业，经常与他们社交。与克里斯蒂不同，阿克谢·昌德的朋友圈非常小。他非常聪明，但在社交方面却很笨拙，尤其是面对女性时。
He and his family had emigrated to New Zealand from BG when he was four years old. As children, Chand and Christy were in the same year at Willow Park Primary School, but they didn't really know one another. They went on to attend different high schools and didn't meet again until they finished school and got jobs at the same supermarket.
他和家人在他四岁时从斐济移民到新西兰。小时候，昌德和克里斯蒂在威洛帕克小学 (Willow Park Primary School) 是同届生，但他们并不真正认识对方。后来他们上了不同的高中，直到毕业并在同一家超市找到工作后才再次相遇。
Christy behind a checkout and Chand at the meat counter. Christy was kind and friendly and as they spent more time working together, Chand began to confide in her. The truth was he was depressed and felt miserable about his life. He wasn't close with his family and felt directionless when it came to his future.
克里斯蒂在收银台工作，昌德在肉类柜台工作。克里斯蒂善良友好，随着他们一起工作的时间增加，昌德开始向她吐露心声。事实是，他感到沮丧，对自己的生活感到痛苦。他和家人关系不亲密，对未来感到迷茫。
Christy felt sorry for Akshay Chand, but his attention towards her had started to feel a little intense. In June 2011, she left her position at the supermarket for a new job at a cheese shop. Without work throwing them together, she saw a lot less of Chand.
克里斯蒂对阿克谢·昌德感到同情，但他对她的关注开始让人觉得有点过头了。2011 年 6 月，她辞去了超市的工作，去了一家奶酪店担任新职。由于没有工作将他们聚在一起，她见到昌德的次数少了很多。
By the time he called her on the morning of September 6th, it had been a while since the pair had spoken. Christy knew how he'd been struggling. Surely, if he was calling her threatening suicide, then he was in serious trouble. It only took a few minutes for Christy to arrive at the apartment building where Chand lived with his mother and younger sister.
到 9 月 6 日早上他打电话给她时，两人已经有一段时间没说话了。克里斯蒂知道他一直在经历怎样的挣扎。当然，如果他打电话威胁要自杀，那么他一定是遇到了严重的麻烦。克里斯蒂只花了几分钟就来到了昌德和他母亲及妹妹居住的公寓楼。
She parked her car on the street and walked up the steps to knock on the property's screen door. Chand answered and invited her in. Christy followed him through the front door, which he locked behind them. There was no one else home. Chand's mother was working and his 16-year-old sister was at school.
她把车停在街上，走上台阶敲了敲房子的纱门。昌德开门并邀请她进去。克里斯蒂跟着他穿过前门，他在他们身后锁上了门。家里没有其他人。昌德的母亲在上班，他 16 岁的妹妹在上学。
As the two teenagers sat down in two chairs facing one another, Christy noticed some white powder on a bench top. It looked as though it had been left after someone had crushed up some pills. Clearly, Chand was serious when he said he'd prepared a drink laced with medication. Christy asked him where the drink was.
当两名青少年面对面坐在两把椅子上时，克里斯蒂注意到长椅台面上有一些白色粉末。看起来就像是某人把一些药丸碾碎后留下的。很显然，昌德说他准备了一杯掺有药物的饮料时是认真的。克里斯蒂问他饮料在哪里。
Do you think I am stupid, he replied. I obviously hid it because I knew that you'd find it. Then he began rambling, telling Christy how he had some specific aims and a task he'd been planning for the day. Concerned, Christy encouraged him to get some professional help. This advice upset Chand.
“你觉得我很蠢吗？”他回答道。“我很明显把它藏起来了，因为我知道你会找到它。”然后他开始语无伦次地唠叨，告诉克里斯蒂他这一天有一些具体的目的和计划好的任务。克里斯蒂感到担忧，鼓励他寻求专业的心理帮助。这个建议让昌德很不高兴。
The way he saw it, Christy had hardly been there for him since she'd left the supermarket. He began ranting, accusing her of not even trying to be his friend. Christy explained that she'd been busy with her university studies and her new job. Chand retorted that she could have taken five minutes
在他看来，自从克里斯蒂离开超市后，她就几乎没有关心过他。他开始咆哮，指责她甚至没有试图做他的朋友。克里斯蒂解释说，她一直忙于大学学业和新工作。昌德反驳说，她本可以花五分钟
to contact him on Facebook and that would have been enough. Then he added, let's face it, we both know that you haven't been very busy. Christy was growing nervous. The more Chand badgered her about why she hadn't attempted to help him,
在 Facebook 上联系他，这就足够了。然后他补充道：“面对现实吧，我们都知道你其实并不忙。”克里斯蒂开始感到紧张。昌德越是纠缠她为什么不试图帮助他，
the more she tried to explain that she wasn't in a position to do so. He needed to see a mental health professional. Chand responded that he didn't need that at all. What he needed was Christy's help. Then he told her that he had cervical cancer. Christy disputed this, informing him that only females could get that disease.
她就越是试图解释说她当时无能为力。他需要去看心理健康专家。昌德回答说他根本不需要那个。他需要的是克里斯蒂的帮助。然后他告诉她他得了宫颈癌。克里斯蒂对此提出异议，告诉他只有女性才会得这种疾病。
Chand abruptly changed his story, claiming he had prostate cancer instead. Making up stories about having cancer was too much for Christy. It was a serious illness, not something to use to get attention. She told Chand as much. His expression grew angry
昌德突然改口，声称自己得的是前列腺癌。编造自己得了癌症的故事对克里斯蒂来说实在是太过分了。这是一场严重的疾病，而不是用来博取关注的手段。她把这些话告诉了昌德。他的表情变得愤怒起来，
and he stood from his chair, looming over her. Suddenly, he reached into the back waistband of his tracksuit pants and pulled out a long kitchen knife. The knife was about 20 centimetres long and very sharp. Chand's right fist tightly held its handle as he waved it over Christy. This is how it's gonna go, he said.
从椅子上站起来，居高临下地逼近她。突然，他把手伸进运动裤后腰，掏出一把长长的厨房用刀。这把刀大约二十厘米长，非常锋利。昌德的右手紧紧握着刀柄，在克里斯蒂面前挥舞着。“事情会是这样的，”他说。
If you scream, I'm gonna knife you. Christy began to sob, which prompted Chand to tell her to shut up and calm down. She was still holding her mobile phone in one hand and thought about texting her best friend for help. But Chand noticed the device and demanded, give me your phone. Christy held onto it tightly.
“如果你尖叫，我就用刀捅你。”克里斯蒂开始啜泣，这促使昌德叫她闭嘴并冷静下来。她手里仍然握着手机，考虑给最好的朋友发短信求助。但昌德注意到了这部手机并命令道：“把你的手机给我。”克里斯蒂紧紧抓住手机不放。
It was the only connection she had to the outside world. Chand tried to wrestle it out of her hand, saying, we can either do this the hard way or the easy way. You know what you'll get if you don't give it to me. He succeeded in prizing the phone away from Christy and placed it out of her reach. Then he turned his attention back to the matter at hand. As he started explaining to Christy,
这是她与外界唯一的联系。昌德试图将手机从她手中抢过来，说道：“我们可以用艰难的方式解决，也可以用简单的方式。如果你不交出来，你知道会有什么后果。”他成功地将手机从克里斯蒂手中夺走，放在了她够不到的地方。然后他把注意力转回了手头的事情。正如他开始向克里斯蒂解释的那样，
Chand had several things he wanted to accomplish that day. First, he wanted to terrify her. Next, he wanted to enact revenge against her for abandoning him. And finally, once those missions were complete, he would take his own life. Christy continued to cry. Chand ordered her to remove her jumper and hand it to him.
昌德那天有几件想完成的事情。首先，他想吓唬她。其次，他想对她抛弃他进行报复。最后，一旦这些任务完成，他就会结束自己的生命。克里斯蒂继续哭泣。昌德命令她脱下套头衫并递给他。
She did, and once the garment was in his hands, he rummaged through its pockets. After finding them empty, Chand demanded Christy take off the blue top she was wearing as well. Christy refused. You know what will happen if you don't do it, Chand warned. Christy pulled the top off over her head
她照做了，衣服落入他手中后，他在口袋里翻找了一番。发现口袋空空如身上后，昌德要求克里斯蒂也脱掉她穿的蓝色上衣。克里斯蒂拒绝了。“如果你不照做，你知道会发生什么，”昌德警告说。克里斯蒂把上衣从头上脱下来，
and passed it to Chand. Then he told her to stand up and prove that she wasn't hiding any objects in her tracksuit pants. Christy did so, emptying both pockets. He then told her to remove her pants. Christy refused and cried even harder. Again, Chand threatened her with the knife. Realizing she had no choice,
递给了昌德。然后他让她站起来，证明她没有在运动裤里藏任何东西。克里斯蒂照做了，掏空了两个口袋。然后他让她脱掉裤子。克里斯蒂拒绝并哭得更厉害了。昌德再次用刀威胁她。意识到自己别无选择，
Christy took off her pants, leaving her only in her underwear. Chand gathered all of her clothes and bundled them into a pile before taking a seat in an armchair. He began talking again. His rantings were confusing and bizarre. Sometimes he discussed the economic system
克里斯蒂脱掉了裤子，只剩下内衣。昌德把她所有的衣服收集起来堆成一堆，然后在靠背椅上坐了下来。他又开始说话了。他语无伦次的话语令人困惑而诡异。有时他长篇大论地讨论资本主义
of capitalism at length. Then he switched to talking about spiritual matters like God and the devil. According to Chand, the devil had tried to grab him one night, and ever since then, he'd been fighting a losing battle against evil. He rambled on and on,
经济制度。然后他又转而谈论上帝和魔鬼等精神层面的事情。据昌德说，魔鬼曾在一个晚上试图抓住他，从那以后，他一直在与邪恶进行着一场注定失败的战斗。他喋喋不休地唠叨着，
complaining that people like Christy caused others to suffer. Chand accused her of only being there for him when it was too late, saying, By now, more than half an hour had passed since Christy had arrived at the apartment. Terrified, she asked. Are you going to kill me? Chand reminded Christy of the three aims he'd had for the day,
抱怨像克里斯蒂这样的人给他人带来了痛苦。昌德指责她只有在为时已晚时才来找他，并说道：“此时距离克里斯蒂到达公寓已经过去半个多小时了。她惊恐万状地问：‘你要杀了我吗？’昌德提醒克里斯蒂他当天设定的三个目标：
to scare her, to get revenge, and to kill himself. He'd never said how he intended to have revenge, but now he was ready to tell her. He planned to rape her. Christy burst into tears again, prompting Chand to tell her to compose herself. Then, all of a sudden, he changed his mind. Abruptly, he told Christy that she could leave.
吓唬她、报复她以及自杀。他从未说过他打算如何报复，但现在他准备告诉她了。他计划强奸她。克里斯蒂再次放声大哭，这促使昌德叫她镇定下来。然后，突然之间，他改变了主意。他突然告诉克里斯蒂她可以离开了。
He returned her clothes and mobile phone. Still petrified, Christy didn't trust Chand's unexpected change of heart. What if he planned to catch her off guard by stabbing her as soon as she turned her back? She aired this fear, prompting Chand to put the knife down. I'm gonna let you go, he said. But I just want you to know that once you leave,
他归还了她的衣服和手机。克里斯蒂依然惊魂未定，不相信昌德突如其来的回心转意。如果他打算在她转身的一瞬间出其不意地捅她一刀怎么办？她表达了这种恐惧，这促使昌德把刀放下了。“我要放你走，”他说。“但我只想让你知道，一旦你离开，
I'm gonna drink the drink I made. Christy briefly paused, trying to convince Chand not to do it. Despite what he'd put her through, her conscience wouldn't allow her to just walk away when he said that. But Chand was insistent. Too scared to stay a minute longer,
我就会喝下我调制的饮料。”克里斯蒂停顿了一下，试图说服昌德不要这么做。尽管他让她经历了那么多痛苦，但当他说出这话时，她的良知不允许她就这样一走了之。但昌德态度坚决。由于害怕再多呆一分钟，
Christy turned and ran out of the apartment. She raced down the stairs that led to ground level and over to her car. Other people were out and about, strolling along the footpath with no idea of what had just happened to her. Christy thought about asking one of them for help, but she knew she wouldn't feel safe
克里斯蒂转身跑出了公寓。她顺着通往地面的楼梯狂奔，跑向自己的汽车。其他人正在外面四处闲逛，沿着人行道漫步，完全不知道刚刚在她身上发生了什么。克里斯蒂考虑向其中一人寻求帮助，但她知道，只有回到自己家中，她才会感到安全。
until she was back in her own home. Once she was in the driver's seat, Christy locked her car doors and started the engine. Then she made her way home. As far as Christy's parents were concerned, she had been their miracle baby. Shortly after having their first child, a girl they named Heather,
一坐上驾驶座，克里斯蒂就锁上了车门并启动了发动机。然后她开车回了家。在克里斯蒂的父母看来，她是他们的奇迹宝宝。在生下他们的第一个孩子——一个名叫海瑟的女孩后不久，
Tracy and Brian Marceau tried to conceive again. It had taken them six long years before Christy was born and their family was complete. Heather and Christy looked the same, but they had very different personalities. Where Heather was quiet and serious, Christy was bubbly and mischievous. Despite these differences and the years between them,
特蕾西 (Tracy) 和布赖恩·马索 (Brian Marceau) 尝试再次怀孕。他们花了整整六年时间才生下克里斯蒂，他们的家庭才算完整。海瑟和克里斯蒂长得很像，但性格却截然不同。海瑟安静而严肃，而克里斯蒂则活泼淘气。尽管有这些差异，且年龄相差几岁，
the two sisters loved each other dearly. By 2011, the close-knit Marceau family was somewhat scattered. Heather had moved out of home years earlier, while Brian worked at a mine in South Australia. He would fly there for weeks at a time and return home to New Zealand when he could. Tracy planned to move to Adelaide in the new year so she could be closer to her husband.
这两个姐妹依然深爱着彼此。到了 2011 年，这个关系紧密的马索家族有些分散了。海瑟几年前就已经搬出了家，而布赖恩则在南澳大利亚的一座矿山工作。他会在那里飞去工作几个星期，并在可能的时候回新西兰的家。特蕾西计划在新的一年搬到阿德莱德，以便离丈夫更近一些。
Christy wanted to go too. She would transfer to an Australian university and was excited at the prospect of living in a new city. On the morning of Christy's attack, Tracy was busy at work when her mobile started ringing at around 11.30. Glancing down at its screen, she saw that her mother Shirley was calling.
克里斯蒂也想去。她将转学到澳大利亚的一所大学，对在一个新城市生活的远景感到兴奋。在克里斯蒂遭受袭击的早晨，特蕾西正在忙于工作，大约 11 点 30 分时她的手机开始响铃。她瞥了一眼屏幕，看到是她的母亲雪莉 (Shirley) 打来的。
Shirley lived with her and granddaughter Christy in a self-contained flat on their house's lower level. Tracy answered the call. She could hear Christy crying hysterically in the background. Then Tracy heard her mother's voice. Love, I think you had better come home. Christy has been attacked. Tracy immediately left work
雪莉和孙女克里斯蒂住在他们家底层的一套独立公寓里。特蕾西接了电话。她能听到背景中克里斯蒂歇斯底里的哭声。接着特蕾西听到了母亲的声音：“亲爱的，我想你最好回家。克里斯蒂遭到袭击了。”特蕾西立刻离开工作岗位，
and was home within 15 minutes. Upon seeing her mother, Christy embraced her and wouldn't let go. Sobbing and shaking the entire time, she told Tracy what Akshay Chant had done to her. Tracy didn't know Chant well. He certainly wasn't one of Christy's friends, though she had mentioned his name
并在 15 分钟内赶回了家。一看到母亲，克里斯蒂就紧紧抱住她不肯放手。她一边哭泣一边浑身发抖，向特蕾西讲述了阿克谢·昌德对她做的事。特蕾西对昌德并不十分了解。他当然不是克里斯蒂的朋友之一，不过自从她开始和他一起在超市工作后，她确实提到过他的名字。
after she started working at the supermarket with him. Christy had described him as a lonely boy with few friends. One Sunday a few months earlier, Tracy and Christy returned home after driving Brian to the airport and found Chant waiting in their driveway. Christy chatted with him for a little while, then he went home.
克里斯蒂曾形容他是一个朋友不多的孤独男孩。几个月前的一个星期天，特蕾西和克里斯蒂开车送布赖恩去机场后回到家，发现昌德在他们的车道上等待。克里斯蒂跟他聊了一会儿，然后他就回家了。
Christy had reassured her mother that Chant just needed to speak to someone who was nice to him, but his behavior unnerved Tracy. There was something about the teenager that made her deeply uncomfortable. She asked Christy not to speak to him anymore. Christy was adamant that he was nothing to worry about
克里斯蒂曾向母亲保证，昌德只是需要和对她好的人说说话，但他的行为让特蕾西感到不安。这个年轻人身上有些东西让她感到深深的不适。她要求克里斯蒂不要再跟他说话了。克里斯蒂坚称他没什么好担心的，
and there were no more incidents that Tracy was aware of until the assault in his home that morning. The details of what had happened to her daughter devastated, terrified and sickened Tracy. She took Christy to North Shore police station to file an official complaint. Christy recounted her ordeal again for the police. She revealed that during the assault,
在当天早上他家里的袭击事件发生之前，特蕾西没有再听说过任何其他事件。女儿遭遇的事情的细节让特蕾西感到崩溃、恐惧和恶心。她带着克里斯蒂去了北岸警察局 (North Shore police station) 报案并做正式记录。克里斯蒂再次向警方讲述了她的遭遇。她透露，在袭击发生期间，
she'd been able to hear the voices of Akshay Chant's neighbors next door. She deliberately tried to cry loudly, hoping they might hear her. She had also tried to placate Chant by agreeing with him when he told her how awful she was, a strategy she'd learned about while watching police procedural programs
她能够听到隔壁阿克谢·昌德邻居的声音。她故意大声哭泣，希望他们能听到。她还试图通过在昌德告诉她她有多糟糕时表示赞同来安抚昌德，这种策略是她在观看诸如《犯罪心理》之类的
like Criminal Minds. Christy had considered trying to escape by running for the front door, but it was locked and she knew that if she fumbled or Chant caught up to her, she'd be in trouble. She even wondered if she should let Chant stab her just once. Perhaps if he did, the reality of the violence
警察办案节目时学到的。克里斯蒂曾考虑过试图逃跑，冲向正门，但门是锁着的，她知道如果自己动作笨拙或者被昌德追上，她就会陷入麻烦。她甚至想过是否应该让昌德捅自己一刀。也许如果他这样做了，暴力的现实就会
would have snapped him out of whatever he was thinking. Then she would have been free to leave and see her family again. Christy had no idea why Chant had suddenly changed his mind and let her go, but she was convinced it wasn't over and that he might attack her again. She revealed that Chant
让他从任何胡思乱想中清醒过来。然后她就可以自由地离开并再次见到她的家人了。克里斯蒂不知道昌德为什么突然改变主意放她走，但她确信事情还没有结束，他可能还会再次袭击她。她透露，昌德
had actually been stalking her for a while. Unbeknownst to her parents, she'd come home to find him sitting on her doorstep more than once. He had also followed her home after a work party where he'd gotten very drunk. Not long after that, he left a note in the letterbox in which he confessed he's loved her and insisted that she help him by becoming his counselor.
实际上已经跟踪她一段时间了。在父母不知情的情况下，她不止一次回家时发现他坐在她家门阶上。在一个他喝得大醉的工作派对后，他还一直尾随她回家。不久之后，他在信箱里留下一张便条，在信中他坦白自己爱她，并坚持让她通过做他的辅导员来帮助他。
Chant also tried to give her a large sum of money as a gift. Christy refused to accept it, but he was insistent. She held onto it, suspecting he would ask for it back. He did a few days later. Chant constantly rambled to Christy about diseases he thought he had or how he hated capitalism, which he blamed for ruining his family.
昌德还试图给她一大笔钱作为礼物。克里斯蒂拒绝接受，但他态度坚决。她把钱留下了，怀疑他会要回去。几天后他果然要了。昌德不断地向克里斯蒂唠叨他认为自己得了什么病，或者他是多么痛恨资本主义，并将此归咎于资本主义毁了他的家庭。
She was polite, but found their conversations frustrating. When Christy resigned from her job at the supermarket, Chant quit on the same day, saying he had no reason to be there if she was gone. It was abundantly clear that he now harbored a lot of anger towards her. She was terrified at the thought that he was still out there. The police officers who took down Christy's statement
她表现得很有礼貌，但觉得他们的对话令人沮丧。当克里斯蒂辞去超市的工作时，昌德在同一天辞职了，理由是如果她走了，他就没有理由留在那儿了。很明显，他现在对她怀有极大的愤怒。一想到他还在外面游荡，她就感到无比恐惧。记录克里斯蒂口供的警官们
understood the danger. Akshay Chant was unpredictable and unstable. They held Christy's concerns that he could strike again. Detectives were quickly dispatched to his residence to place him under arrest. After Christy had left Chant's home, he retrieved the drink he'd prepared earlier. He'd filled it with around 50 crushed multivitamin tablets,
意识到了危险。阿克谢·昌德喜怒无常且极不稳定。他们认为克里斯蒂担心他会再次袭击的担忧是合理的。侦探们被迅速派往他的住所将他逮捕。在克里斯蒂离开昌德的家后，他取回了早些时候准备的饮料。里面装满了大约 50 粒压碎的复合维生素片，
which he'd stolen from his mother. He had read somewhere that consuming a large quantity of multivitamins had a toxic effect on the human body. Chant had swallowed the drink, intending to end his life. Sometime later, his 16-year-old sister returned home from school. Chant asked her to call an ambulance for him,
这些药丸是他从母亲那里偷来的。他曾在某处读到过，摄入大量的复合维生素会对人体产生毒性作用。昌德喝下了这杯饮料，企图结束自己的生命。一段时间后，他 16 岁的妹妹放学回家。昌德请她为自己叫一辆救护车，
and the paramedics took him to North Shore Hospital's emergency department. Once there, Chant was assessed by a psychiatric registrar and a nurse. He admitted to feeling depressed and unloved and said his parents couldn't care less about his struggles. He hadn't always felt this way. As a child, Akshay Chant had always been quiet and shy
医护人员将他送往北岸医院的急诊室。到达后，昌德接受了一名精神科住院医师和一名护士的评估。他承认自己感到沮丧和缺爱，并说他的父母对他的挣扎漠不关心。他并非一直都是这样的。小时候，阿克谢·昌德一直安静而害羞，
but enjoyed periods of happiness. When he was eight years old, his family had relocated to Wales for his father's work. Chant flourished in the UK and would later reflect on his time there as the happiest he'd ever been. But in less than two years, Chant moved back to New Zealand with his mother and sister.
但也享受过快乐的时光。八岁时，他的家人因他父亲的工作搬到了威尔士。昌德在英国生活得很滋润，后来他回忆起在那里的时光是他一生中最快乐的时光。但在不到两年的时间里，昌德和母亲及妹妹搬回了新西兰。
His father stayed behind. Soon, Chant's parents had announced their plans to separate. After that, he had little to do with his father. The young boy was academically brilliant with teachers describing him as smart, polite and full of potential. However, by his mid-teens,
他的父亲留在了当地。不久，昌德的父母宣布了分居计划。此后，他与父亲几乎没有什么来往。这个小男孩在学业上非常优秀，老师们形容他聪明、有礼貌且极具潜力。然而，到了青少年中期，
his grades were rapidly falling. Instead of going on to university as many had expected, Chant didn't even graduate his final year at school. Though he had previously had a small group of close friends, his social life dwindled as he became more withdrawn, spending most of his time holed up in his bedroom. He would read, listen to music and play chess online. Chant became fixated with capitalism
他的成绩急剧下降。正如许多人预料的那样，昌德不仅没有去上大学，甚至连高中的最后一年都没有毕业。尽管他以前有一个关系密切的小圈子，但随着他变得越来越孤僻，将大部分时间关在卧室里，他的社交生活也随之萎缩。他看书、听音乐并在网上下棋。昌德对资本主义产生了执念，
after reading Das Kapital by German philosopher and economist Karl Marx. At night, he struggled to sleep. And would make up for it by staying in bed the next day. His weight fluctuated, but he never abused drugs or alcohol. His lack of motivation led him to resisting his mother's entreaties that he resume his studies
这是在阅读了德国哲学家兼经济学家卡尔·马克思的《资本网论》之后。到了晚上，他很难入睡。为了弥补这一点，他第二天一整天都赖在床上。他的体重经常波动，但他从未滥用过毒品或酒精。他缺乏动力，导致他抗拒母亲恳求他恢复学业
or find a job. Chant was exhibiting classic symptoms of depression. Eventually, his aunt organized a job for him at the same supermarket where she worked. It was there that he met Christy Marso, one of the few girls who he felt comfortable speaking to. Soon, he was opening up to her about his problems. Though Chant told the hospital staff
或找一份工作的要求。昌德表现出典型的抑郁症症状。最终，他的姑姑为他在她工作的同一家超市安排了一份工作。正是在那里，他遇到了克里斯蒂·马索，她是少数几个让他觉得可以自在交谈的女孩之一。很快，他就开始向她倾诉自己的问题。尽管昌德向医院工作人员
how awful he'd been feeling and how rejected he felt by his peers, he mentioned nothing about Christy or what he'd done to her earlier that day. The psychiatric registrar diagnosed Chant as having depression with suicidality. He found no symptoms of psychosis but made a point of writing in his notes.
讲述了他感觉多么糟糕以及被同龄人拒绝的感觉，但他没有提及克里斯蒂或他当天早些时候对她做的事。精神科住院医师诊断昌德患有伴有自杀倾向的抑郁症。他没有发现精神病症状，但特别在病历中写道：
Some grandiose or entitled flavor to his discussion, also slightly narcissistic. He prescribed Chant with an antidepressant and referred him to a community mental health team for follow-up. When the police arrived at Chant's residence, they found only his mother at home. She had no idea where her son was.
他的谈话中带有某种宏大或自命不凡的色彩，同时也略带自恋。他给昌德开抗抑郁药，并将其转介给社区心理健康团队进行跟进。当警方到达昌德的住所时，发现只有他的母亲在家。她根本不知道她的儿子在哪里。
The officers managed to track him down at North Shore Hospital where they began to interview him. As police queried him about each stage of the attack against Christy, Chant responded to almost every question by simply saying, yeah. Within minutes, he'd admitted to everything. That same evening, he was charged with kidnapping,
警官们设法在北岸医院追踪到了他，并开始对其实施盘问。当警方就对克里斯蒂袭击的每个阶段进行盘问时，昌德对几乎每个问题都简单地回答：“嗯。”几分钟内，他就供认了一切。当天晚上，他被指控绑架、
assault with intent to commit sexual violation and threatening to do grievous bodily harm. Chant was transferred to the police station so a formal interview could take place. He said that he'd been planning to rape Christy but inexplicably changed his mind and decided to let her go. His motive for the entire attack had been revenge.
意图实施性侵犯的袭击以及威胁造成严重身体伤害。昌德被转移到警察局以便进行正式讯问。他说他原本计划强奸克里斯蒂，但莫名其妙地改变了主意，决定放她走。他整个袭击的动机是报复。
Chant said that he'd been furious at Christy for not helping him with his depression and admitted to still wanting vengeance. Although Akshay Chant had never been in trouble before, the police were extremely concerned by the violent nature of his crimes. As one of the station's detectives noted, his actions were quite a big jump
昌德说，他因为克里斯蒂没有帮他摆脱抑郁而对她感到愤怒，并承认仍然想要报复。尽管阿克谢·昌德以前从未惹过麻烦，但警方对他的犯罪暴力性质深表担忧。正如该局的一名侦探指出的那样，对于一个从未犯罪过的人来说，
for somebody who had never offended before. Plus, he was apparently still harboring anger towards Christy. The officers were in no doubt as to what should happen next. Chant should be kept in custody until the case could go to court. Detective Sergeant James Watson prepared a document titled Grounds for Opposing Bail.
他的行为是一个相当大的跨越。此外，他显然对克里斯蒂仍然怀恨在心。警官们对下一步该怎么做毫不怀疑。昌德应该被关押在拘留所，直到案件可以开庭审理。侦探警长詹姆斯·沃森 (James Watson) 准备了一份名为《反对保释的理由》的文件。
In it, he detailed how Akshay Chant had admitted to attacking and detaining Christy Marso with the intent of sexually assaulting her. His confession meant that a conviction was extremely likely and incarceration would be inevitable given the seriousness of his crimes. Detective Watson made a particular point of noting Christy's extreme fear of Chant
他在文件中详细说明了阿克谢·昌德如何承认袭击并拘禁克里斯蒂·马索，企图对她实施性侵犯。他的供述意味着定罪的可能性极大，鉴于其犯罪的严重性，监禁将是不可避免的。沃森侦探特别指出，克里斯蒂对昌德有着极度的恐惧，
and her desire that he be detained. The proximity of their homes to one another meant that he could be at her house within minutes if he decided to strike again. Three days after the attack, Akshay Chant appeared in court. His attorney argued her client should be granted bail as he was just 18 years old.
并且强烈希望将其拘留。他们两家住所相距甚近，这意味着如果他决定再次袭击，几分钟内就能到达她家。袭击发生三天后，阿克谢·昌德出庭受审。他的辩护律师辩称，她的当事人应该获得保释，因为他年仅 18 岁。
The country's bail act at the time meant that defendants who were over the age of 17 but under the age of 20 must be released on bail unless they had a prior conviction. Chant had no previous arrests, let alone convictions. Chant's attorney conceded that his mental health issues were a factor but explained he was about to start taking antidepressants.
该国当时的保释法规定，年龄超过 17 岁但未满 20 岁的被告必须予以保释，除非他们有前科。昌德以前没有被捕记录，更谈不上定罪。昌德的律师承认他的心理健康问题是一个因素，但解释说他即将开始服用抗抑郁药。
If given bail, he would live with his mother so she could supervise him. He would also attend a psychiatric appointment within a week of release. The police prosecutor protested these conditions telling judge Barbara Morris that Chant's mother's home was totally inappropriate. If traveling by car,
如果获得保释，他将和母亲住在一起，以便母亲监督他。他还将在获释后的一周内参加精神科预约。警方检察官抗议这些条件，告诉法官芭芭拉·莫里斯 (Barbara Morris)，昌德母亲的家完全不合适。如果乘汽车出行，
it was approximately one kilometer from Christy Marso's house. It was even closer to reach by foot. Chant and Christy's homes sat in streets that were practically parallel to one another and just 350 meters apart. Chant could cut across a reserve that separated their two blocks and be at the Marso residence within five minutes.
它距离克里斯蒂·马索的房子大约一公里。步行到达甚至更近。昌德和克里斯蒂的家所在的街道实际上彼此平行，相距仅 350 米。昌德可以穿过分隔他们两个街区的保护区，在五分钟内到达马索的住所。
Judge Morris agreed that such an arrangement was unacceptable. Despite the bail act, the only way she would consider providing bail was if Chant agreed to stay at a mental health facility. However, it was unlikely such a facility would accept him as he wasn't exhibiting the sorts of symptoms that required intervention
莫里斯法官同意这种安排是不可接受的。尽管有保释法，她唯一会考虑给予保释的情况是昌德同意留在心理健康机构。然而，这样的机构不太可能接纳他，因为他并没有表现出根据新西兰《精神健康法》需要进行干预的种种症状。
in accordance with New Zealand's Mental Health Act. Ultimately, judge Morris ordered that Akshay Chant receive a full psychiatric assessment and denied him bail, citing public safety concerns and Christy Marso's anxieties. I must take her wishes into account, judge Morris said. I do not consider it prudent or wise to grant bail until at least a full forensic report can be obtained.
最终，莫里斯法官下令对阿克谢·昌德进行全面的精神病学评估，并以公共安全问题和克里斯蒂·马索的焦虑为由拒绝了他的保释。“我必须考虑她的愿望，”莫里斯法官说。“在至少获得全面的法医报告之前，我认为准予保释既不明智也不明智。”
Meanwhile, Christy was struggling. The traumatic ordeal she had suffered shattered her sense of safety and security. Her father Brian was still away in Australia and wouldn't be returning for almost a week. Christy knew that if she told him about the assault, he would fly home immediately. Not wanting to cause her father any distress,
与此同时，克里斯蒂一直在苦苦挣扎。她遭受的创伤性磨难粉碎了她的安全感。她的父亲布赖恩仍在澳大利亚，将近一周内都不会回来。克里斯蒂知道，如果她把袭击的事告诉他，他会立刻飞回国。为了不让父亲担心，
she decided not to tell him what had happened until he arrived back. Christy was too scared to sleep in her own room, which sat on the lower level of her home. She initially slept beside her mother. After two weeks, she moved into the spare room next to her parents. Eventually, she was able to return to her own bed,
她决定等他回来后再把发生的事情告诉他。克里斯蒂太害怕了，不敢睡在她位于家底层的自己的房间里。她最初和母亲睡在一起。两周后，她搬进了父母隔壁的客房。最终，她能够回到自己的床上，
but if she heard strange sounds during the night, she would ask her mom and dad to check up on them. Christy also no longer felt safe taking public transport. Her parents would drop her off at work or university, then collect her afterwards. She kept a diary and saw a counsellor to deal with the trauma she had been left with. Her greatest fear was that Akshay Chand would be released.
但如果她在夜间听到奇怪的声音，她会请爸爸妈妈去查看。克里斯蒂也不再觉得乘坐公共交通工具是安全的。她的父母会开车送她去上班或上学，然后再去接她。她写日记，并去看心理咨询师以处理留下的创伤。她最大的恐惧是阿克谢·昌德会被释放。
She wasn't only scared for her own life, she was terrified he might target her family or become fixated with another girl. By early November, life was slowly starting to feel good again. Chand was finally going to trial on Wednesday, November 9th, and in a couple of months, Christy and her parents would be moving to Australia.
她不仅害怕自己的生命安全，还担心他会把目标对准她的家人或对另一个女孩产生执念。到了 11 月初，生活慢慢开始感觉好起来了。昌德终于要在 11 月 9 日星期三受审，几个月后，克里斯蒂和她的父母将搬到澳大利亚。
What was initially planned as an exciting new chapter was now going to be the opportunity for a much needed fresh start. On the morning of Sunday, November 6th, Christy and Tracy went out for brunch together. Christy was seeing a friend to later that day, but was keen to spend some quality time with her mum beforehand.
原本计划作为一个令人兴奋的新篇章，现在将成为一个急需重新开始的机会。11 月 6 日星期日早晨，克里斯蒂和特蕾西一起出去吃早午餐。克里斯蒂那天晚些时候要见一个朋友，但在此之前渴望和妈妈共度一段美好时光。
She was determined to have pancakes, so they went from cafe to cafe until they found one that had them on the menu. As they sat and ate, the two happily discussed their upcoming plans. Tracy and Brian were planning to take Christy to see some pandas at the zoo. Christy planned to wear a panda hat she owned
她一心想吃煎饼，于是他们一家一家咖啡馆地找，直到找到一家菜单上有煎饼的。当他们坐着吃东西时，两人开心地讨论着他们即将到来的计划。特蕾西和布赖恩计划带克里斯蒂去动物园看大熊猫。克里斯蒂计划戴一顶她自己的熊猫帽子
for the occasion, as they chatted. Christy made a point of saying to Tracy, Mum, I love you. The next morning, Tracy got up at 6.30 to get ready for work. She let the family dogs outside, ate breakfast and took a shower. Still wearing her dressing gown,
以应景，在他们聊天时。克里斯蒂特意对特蕾西说：“妈妈，我爱你。”第二天早上，特蕾西 6 点 30 分起床准备上班。她把家里的狗放出去，吃早餐并洗了个澡。依然穿着晨衣，
she was preparing to get dressed for the day when there was a knock at the front door. It was still early, about 7 a.m., but Tracy wasn't surprised by the knock. Christy liked to shop online and her orders were usually delivered at the start of the day. As Christy was still in bed,
她正准备换衣服开始新的一天时，前门传来了敲门声。当时还很早，大约早上 7 点，但特蕾西对敲门声并不感到意外。克里斯蒂喜欢网上购物，她的订单通常在一天开始时送达。由于克里斯蒂还在床上，
sleeping in before a late morning shift at work, Tracy went to answer the door herself. Standing on the doorstep was a young man. Tracy didn't recognise him at first. Then, Tracy realised it was Akshay Chant. He was holding a knife. Tara washed over Tracy as Chant pushed his way inside, brandishing the weapon at her.
在临近上午的工作班次前睡懒觉，特蕾西便亲自去开门。门阶上站着一个年轻男子。特蕾西起初没有认出他。然后，特蕾西意识到那是阿克谢·昌德。他手里拿着一把刀。当昌德挤进屋里并向她挥舞武器时，恐惧袭上特蕾西心头。
She screamed as loudly as she could, hoping Christy would hear, realise something dangerous was happening and escape, or maybe some neighbours would hear and call for help. Still threatening Tracy with the knife, Chant asked who else was in the house. Thinking quickly, Tracy told him her husband was home. It was a lie. He had gone back to Australia for work.
她尽最大努力大声尖叫，希望克里斯蒂能听到，意识到有什么危险的事情正在发生并逃跑，或者也许一些邻居会听到并报警。昌德依然用刀威胁着特蕾西，问家里还有谁。特蕾西急中生智，告诉他她丈夫在家。这是一个谎言。他已经回澳大利亚工作了。
Chant seemed to know this, prompting Tracy to wonder if he'd been watching them for some time. Suddenly, Christy appeared on the staircase near Tracy and Chant, barefoot and wearing a t-shirt and boxer shorts. Her mother's screams had woken her and she walked up from her bedroom to see what was wrong. Upon seeing Chant, Christy screamed, oh my god.
昌德似乎知道了这一点，这让特蕾西怀疑他是否已经监视他们一段时间了。突然，克里斯蒂出现在特蕾西和昌德附近的楼梯上，赤着脚，穿着 T 恤和拳击短裤。她母亲的尖叫声把她吵醒了，她从卧室走上来查看发生了什么。一看到昌德，克里斯蒂尖叫道：“哦，我的天呐。”
Frozen with fear, she stood at the top of the stairs without moving. Chant continued to point the knife at Tracy, while edging closer to Christy. Then he kicked her square in the chest, sending her tumbling down the stairs. Christy fell back, then managed to get to her feet. She scrambled down the rest of the staircase.
她吓得僵住了，站在楼梯顶上一动不动。昌德继续用刀指着特蕾西，同时向克里斯蒂逼近。然后他正中她的胸口踢了一脚，把她踢得滚下了楼梯。克里斯蒂向后跌倒，随后设法站起身来。她连滚带爬地下完了剩下的楼梯。
In her rush, she slipped and fell again. Then she got up and ran through the self-contained flat where her grandma Shirley lived, out towards the back garden. Chant chased after her. Tracy decided to call for help. Given what Chant had done the last time, she thought he was intending to threaten and scare Christy. Surely once her daughter reached downstairs,
在慌乱中，她滑倒并再次摔倒。然后她爬起来，穿过了奶奶雪莉居住的独立公寓，朝着后花园跑去。昌德在后面追赶她。特蕾西决定报警。鉴于昌德上次所做的事，她以为他是想威胁和吓唬克里斯蒂。一旦她的女儿下了楼，
she would be able to lock herself in Shirley's flat, preventing Chant from reaching her. The police were familiar with the case and would prioritize her call. They'd be here within minutes and could arrest Chant. Panicked, Tracy dialled emergency services. Police sent police, she begged the operator. There's a guy got into our house and he's after my daughter. Just as she gave her address, she heard a scream.
她肯定能把自己锁在雪莉的公寓里，阻止昌德接近她。警方对这个案子很熟悉，会优先处理她的电话。他们几分钟内就会赶到，并能逮捕昌德。特蕾西惊慌失措地拨打了紧急服务电话。“警察，派警察来，”她哀求接线员。“有个家伙闯进我们家里，他在追我的女儿。”就在她报出地址时，她听到了一声尖叫。
It was Christy. Tracy dropped the phone and ran downstairs. Christy was lying on the deck outside in the garden. There was a pool of blood beneath her. Chant was standing nearby. Tracy raced to her daughter and held Christy in her arms. She couldn't see any injuries on her front, but Christy didn't seem able to move.
那是克里斯蒂。特蕾西放下电话跑下楼。克里斯蒂倒在外面花园的露台上。她身下一片血泊。昌德正站在附近。特蕾西冲向女儿，把克里斯蒂抱在怀里。她看不到克里斯蒂胸前有任何伤口，但克里斯蒂似乎无法动弹。
It looked like she was struggling to breathe. Tracy repeatedly told her daughter that she loved her and encouraged her to hold on because help was on the way. It looked to Tracy as though Christy was trying to tell her something. Then as she gazed into Christy's eyes, Tracy saw the light go out of them. Christy had died. Chant was still standing nearby.
看起来她呼吸困难。特蕾西一遍又一遍地告诉女儿她爱她，鼓励她坚持住，因为救援正在赶来。在特蕾西看来，克里斯蒂似乎正试图告诉她什么。然后，当她凝视着克里斯蒂的眼睛时，特蕾西看到克里斯蒂眼中的光芒熄灭了。克里斯蒂死了。昌德仍然站在附近。
As Tracy turned her attention to him, she saw the knife remained in his hand. Its blade now bent at a 90 degree angle. Chant was covered in blood. Not caring if he attacked her next, Tracy screamed at him that he had killed Christy. In an emotionless voice, he replied, I am glad.
当特雷西把注意力转向他时，她看到他手里依然握着那把刀。刀刃现在已经弯曲成了90度。钱特浑身是血。特雷西不顾他接下来是否会袭击自己，冲着他大喊，说他杀死了克里斯蒂。他用毫无感情的声音回答道：“我很高兴。”
Police arrived at the scene less than 10 minutes after the attack began. Chant was still standing in the backyard, listening to music on an iPod. The bent and broken knife now lay on the ground. An officer approached him and asked why he was there. Chant replied, Reprisal. Another officer noticed that Chant's hands were shaking
警察在袭击开始不到10分钟后就赶到了现场。钱特仍然站在后院里，用iPod听着音乐。那把弯曲破碎的刀此时正躺在地上。一名警官走近他，问他为什么在这里。钱特回答道：“报复。”另一名警官注意到钱特的双手在颤抖，
and asked him why. He answered, It's not easy to kill someone, is it? Chant was placed under arrest and taken to North Shore Police Station. Tracy had the painful task of notifying her other daughter Heather and her husband Brian of what had happened to Christy. Heather immediately rushed over to be with her family, but Brian had to catch two separate flights from Australia to make it back to Auckland.
便问他为什么。他回答说：“杀一个人并不容易，对吧？”钱特随即便被逮捕，并被带到了北岸警察局。特雷西不得不痛苦地将克里斯蒂遭遇的不幸通知她的另一个女儿希瑟和丈夫布莱恩。希瑟立刻赶来陪伴家人，但布莱恩不得不搭乘两趟不同的航班从澳大利亚赶回奥克兰。
A police officer met him as soon as he's plane landed in New Zealand and a sobbing Brian was rushed through customs. The grief-stricken Marso's had been terrified that something like this would happen, ever since Akshay Chant had been granted bail about one month earlier. Although Judge Barbara Morris had initially refused bail when Chant was first arrested for kidnapping Christy in September, she had requested that further reports be commissioned, with a view to reconsidering the matter soon.
就在他的飞机在新西兰降落的那一刻，一名警官迎面走向他，悲痛欲绝的布莱恩被急速护送通过海关。自从大约一个月前阿克沙伊·钱特获得保释以来，心碎的马索夫妇就一直惊恐万分，唯恐发生这样的事。尽管巴尔芭拉·莫里斯法官在9月份钱特因绑架克里斯蒂首次被捕时最初拒绝了保释，但她曾要求进一步出具报告，以便尽快重新审视此事。
Chant's age and his lack of priors entitled him to bail under New Zealand law. He and his lawyer quickly filed a second application. As well as commencing medication and receiving further mental health reviews, Chant had written a seemingly heartfelt letter to the court expressing his remorse for attacking Christy. It read in part, I am incredibly sorry for the ordeal I put Christy through. Given the chance, I will apologise to her, her parents and anyone else affected. Ironically, the last thing she said to me was that she was sorry.
根据新西兰法律，钱特的年龄以及没有前科使他有权获得保释。他和他的律师迅速提交了第二份保释申请。除了开始服药和接受进一步的精神健康评估外，钱特还向法院写了一封看似发自内心的信，表达了他对袭击克里斯蒂的悔意。信中部分写道：“对于我让克里斯蒂经历的磨难，我感到无比抱歉。如果有机会，我会向她、她的父母以及所有受此影响的人道歉。具有讽刺意味的是，她对我说出的最后一句话是她感到抱歉。”
It's only after the events of the day that she realised how much pain depression had caused me and how much I needed her and vice versa. She was my emotional outlet. There was nothing I couldn't tell her and device versa. She's really adamant and I'm sure she feels she's the one to blame. I take full responsibility for my actions and accept the consequences of my wrongdoings. Christy also submitted her own letter, pleading that Chant be denied bail. She wrote,
“直到经历了当天的事件后，她才意识到抑郁症给我带来了多少痛苦，以及我是多么需要她，反之亦然。她是我情感的宣泄口。没有什么是我不能告诉她的，反之亦然。她非常坚定，而且我确信她觉得错在她自己。我为自己的行为承担全部责任，并接受我错误行为带来的后果。”克里斯蒂也提交了自己的信，恳求法院拒绝钱特的保释。她写道：
I am worried that he may still try to get revenge on me as he is already in trouble and has nothing to lose if he tries again. This causes me to worry for my safety. I would like to get on with my life, but at present, I need to know that I don't have to encounter him as I try to restore my faith in people. This has caused me a lot of distress. Chant's application was heard on October 5 before Judge David McNaughton. Although the judge read Christy's letter and was aware police wanted to keep the defendant
“我担心他可能仍会试图对我进行报复，因为他本就麻烦缠身，如果再次下手，他已经没有什么可失去的了。这让我为自己的安全感到担忧。我想继续我的生活，但目前，我需要确信在试图重建对人们的信任时，我不会与他狭路相逢。这给我带来了极大的困扰。”钱特的申请于10月5日在大卫·麦克诺顿法官面前受审。尽管法官阅读了克里斯蒂的信，并且知道警方希望将被告
in custody, he made the decision to grant Akshay's request. He made the decision to grant Akshay Chant bail. He was to stay at his mother's home just 350 meters from Christy's under constant family supervision. He was only permitted to leave for medical and illegal appointments, which he had to attend with a chaperone. And he was barred from having any contact whatsoever with Christy Marceau. The police were bitterly disappointed at this turn of events, but they reassured the Marceaus that they would protect them. Officers would perform random checks to ensure Chant was home
收押，但他还是做出了批准阿克沙伊请求的决定。他做出了批准阿克沙伊·钱特保释的决定。他将被安置在他母亲的家中，该住所距离克里斯蒂的家仅350米，并在家人的全程监督下生活。他只被允许在有陪同人员的情况下，因医疗和非法的（注：原文illegal应为legal，此处按直译或语境保留，译为“法律相关的/合法的”）预约外出，而且被严格禁止与克里斯蒂·马索发生任何形式的接触。警方对这一事态发展感到极其失望，但他们向马索夫妇保证会保护他们。警官将在一天中的不同时间进行随机检查，以确保钱特呆在家中。
at various times of the day. Every single officer working across the North Shore was also briefed on the case, so they could keep an eye out for Chant. In total, police had checked on Chant's 23 times during the 32 days he was out. He had been home every time. Despite their assurances, Christy's fear escalated. During the month that Chant had been in custody, she had slowly been trying to return to life as she'd known it before. The small sense of security that she'd gradually regained was shattered in an instant. Knowing that Chant was free and living mere meters away from her had made her feel more unsafe than ever before. 32 days later, he showed up at her doorstep with a knife.
北岸地区的每一位警官也都听取了该案的情况汇报，以便他们能够密切关注钱特。在钱特获释的32天里，警方总共对他进行了23次突击检查。他每次都在家。尽管有种种保证，克里斯蒂的恐惧却日益加剧。在钱特被关押的一个月里，她一直在慢慢地试图回归她以前所熟悉的生活。那种她逐渐重新获得的微小安全感在瞬间粉碎了。得知钱特已经重获自由，并且就住在离她仅仅几米远的地方，这让她感到前所未有地缺乏安全感。32天后，他拿着一把刀出现在了她家门口。
Forensic experts processed the crime scene at the Marceau residence. Photographs were taken of the blood spatters across the deck and murder weapon, which had become bent and broken after Chant viciously stabbed Christy between 10 and 15 times. He'd attacked her from behind, delivering a violent blow to the back of her head. The force of this had caused Christy to fall to the ground, where Chant continued to stab her in the back. The initial wound had been so incapacitating that Christy would have felt little after that. Akshay Chant was interviewed at length by Detective Darren Atwood. As with the first attack, he appeared extremely calm and admitted to everything.
法医专家对马索住宅的犯罪现场进行了处理。警方对露台上的血迹以及凶器进行了拍照，这把凶器在钱特残忍地刺中克里斯蒂10到15刀后已经变得弯曲且破碎。他是从背后袭击她的，对她的后脑勺给予了猛烈的一击。这股力量导致克里斯蒂摔倒在地，而钱特则继续刺戳她的背部。最初的伤势是如此致命，以至于克里斯蒂在那之后几乎感觉不到什么痛苦了。侦探达伦·阿特伍德对阿克沙伊·钱特进行了长时间的讯问。和第一次袭击一样，他显得异常冷静，对一切供认不讳。
Chant had been plotting to kill Christy for some time. Despite seemingly having a change of heart and releasing Christy the first time he assaulted her, Chant never let go of his desire for revenge. He started thinking about killing her while he was in custody after this initial attack. He knew he'd had to get out of jail so he could follow through with it. He had feigned remorse in his letter to Judge McNaughton in the hopes this would increase his chances of getting bail. Once he was out, he began to make plans. Chant knew that Christy and her family would be on guard in the days following his release, so he decided to bide his time. If he waited a few weeks before striking,
钱特策划杀害克里斯蒂已经有一段时间了。尽管在第一次袭击克里斯蒂时，他似乎回心转意并释放了她，但钱特从未放弃过复仇的欲望。在最初的袭击后被关押期间，他开始盘算着杀掉她。他知道自己必须出狱，才能将计划付诸实施。他在写给麦克诺顿法官的信中假装忏悔，希望这能增加他获得保释的机会。一旦重获自由，他便开始制定计划。钱特知道，在他获释后的几天里，克里斯蒂和她的家人一定会保持警惕，因此他决定暂避锋芒、等待时机。如果他在动手前等待几个星期，
then he was more likely to catch her unawares. Although the judge had believed Chant would be under constant supervision, his mother, Suchita, had to work most days. His younger sister, who was just 16, was scared of Chant and started staying over at friends' houses to avoid being near him. Before going to work, Suchita made a point of hiding all the kitchen knives in a secret compartment beneath the oven, but Chant knew what she was doing and had managed to sneak one away about a week earlier. He'd woken up at 6.30am that morning, knowing that it was the day. He was heading back to court
那么他就更有可能趁她不备将其抓获。尽管法官相信钱特会受到持续监督，但他的母亲苏奇塔大部分时间都需要工作。他年仅16岁的妹妹很害怕钱特，开始到朋友家过夜，以此来避免靠近他。苏奇塔在去上班之前，特意把所有的厨房刀具藏在烤箱下方的一个秘密隔间里，但钱特知道她在做什么，并在大约一周前设法偷偷拿走了一把。他在那天早晨6点30分醒来，深知这一天就是动手的时候。他将在两天后
in two days' time, so Christy probably thought she was safe. As Chant remarked to the detective, when you've got nothing to lose, nothing to gain, it becomes completely viable to kill someone. He got out of bed and brushed his hair, which he didn't usually bother to do. Then he went to his closet, where he'd stashed a bag containing the stolen knife. Suchita had already left for the day, but his sister was in bed asleep, so Chant made sure to leave quietly. As he began walking towards Christy's house, he put his headphones on and repeatedly listened to Up on the Ladder by Radiohead on his iPod. In one interpretation of the song's lyrics, they detailed the emotional torment and frustration
重返法庭，所以克里斯蒂很可能觉得自己是安全的。正如钱特向侦探所说的那样，当你一无所有、无可失去时，杀一个人就变得完全切实可行了。他起床并梳理了头发，这通常是他懒得去做的。然后他走到衣橱前，那里藏着一个装有偷来刀具的袋子。苏奇塔已经出门上班了，但他妹妹还在床上睡觉，所以钱特确保自己悄悄离开。当他开始走向克里斯蒂的家时，他戴上耳机，在iPod上反复听着电台司令乐队的《Up on the Ladder》。对这首歌歌词的一种解读是，它们详细描绘了一个情感上的折磨与挫折：
of a man who seeks an answer from the woman he loves as to where their relationship is heading. However, Chant understood it. He felt the song had been written especially for and about him. Chant detailed how he'd reached the Marso residence in mere minutes, then forced his way past Tracy. He'd chased Christy through the house and out into the garden. She had been attempting to unlatch a gate and escape when he caught up to her. He stabbed her until his knife became twisted and unusable, then stood back and watched as Tracy ran out and cradled her dying daughter. Chant felt absolutely no guilt or remorse about taking Christy's life.
一个男人向他所爱的女人寻求答案，想知道他们的关系将走向何方。然而，无论钱特是如何理解的，他觉得这首歌简直就是专门为他而写、并以他为主题创作的。钱特详细描述了他是如何在短短几分钟内到达马索住宅，然后强行冲过特雷西的阻拦的。他在屋里追赶着克里斯蒂，一直追到了花园里。当时她正试图解开大门栓逃跑，结果被他追上了。他不停地刺她，直到刀子变得扭曲而无法使用，然后退到一旁，看着特雷西跑出来，抱住她垂死的女儿。钱特对夺走克里斯蒂的生命没有感到一丝一毫的内疚或悔意。
As he explained to detectives, she deserved to die because she let me down. Police charged Akshay Chant with murder. He then warned that he had a female accomplice, and even if he was locked up, his collaborator would continue to kill. The police again prepared paperwork to prevent Chant receiving bail, but this time he didn't even apply for it. Two days later, Tracy Marso went to North Shore Police Station to provide a statement. The only way she was able to function was by taking medication, but the interview was still extremely difficult. Tracy was battling guilt for having opened the
正如他向侦探们解释的那样，她罪有应得，因为她让我失望了。警方以谋杀罪起诉了阿克沙伊·钱特。他随后警告说，他有一个女性同伙，即使他被关进监狱，他的同伙也会继续杀人。警方再次准备文件以阻止钱特获得保释，但这一次他甚至都没有申请保释。两天后，特雷西·马索前往北岸警察局提供陈述。她唯一能维持正常运转的方式就是靠服用药物，但这次讯问依然极其艰难。特雷西因为给女儿的杀手开了
door to her daughter's killer, not realizing it was Chant standing before her until it was too late. She wished she had fought him off rather than calling the police. She was tormented by the thought of how scared Christy was in her final moments. All I can see, all I will ever see, is my daughter lying on my lap, gasping, covered in blood, and just dying for some pointless reason, Tracy told the officers. He just stood there and watched it. He didn't even try to get away. What sort of person is that? After Christy was kidnapped by Chant in September, she'd spoken to a close friend about what sort of funeral she would like if she died unexpectedly.
门而深陷内疚之中，直到为时已晚，她才认出站在眼前的人竟然是钱特。她多么希望自己当时是把对方击退，而不是报警。克里斯蒂在最后时刻是多么恐惧，这个想法折磨着她。“我所能看到的，我将永远看到的，只有我的女儿躺在我的膝头，大口喘气，浑身是血，为了一个毫无意义的理由就这样死去，”特雷西对警官们说，“他只是站在那里看着。他甚至没有试图逃跑。这算是什么样的人？”自从克里斯蒂在9月份被钱特绑架后，她曾与一位密友谈起过，如果自己遭遇意外身亡，她希望举行什么样的葬礼。
Christy envisaged a celebration that would reflect who she was and where people could have fun. Her family selected a bright turquoise-colored casket, as the color was Christy's favorite. They and her friends wrote messages of love on it. Christy's boyfriend helped choose the clothes she would be dressed in. She was laid to rest on Saturday, November 12th, five days after her death. Hundreds of mourners attended, with many having to stand outside in the chapel's car park due to a lack of space. A photo slideshow of Christy set to music screened for 10 minutes. In a book titled Christy, that Tracy later co-authored about her daughter,
克里斯蒂设想的是一个能够反映她的个性、并能让大家感到快乐的欢庆仪式。她的家人挑选了一个亮青蓝色的棺材，因为这个颜色是克里斯蒂的最爱。她和她的朋友们在上面写满了爱的寄语。克里斯蒂的男友帮忙挑选了她入殓时穿的衣服。11月12日星期六，也就是她去世五天后，她入土为安了。数百名哀悼者前来参加，由于空间不足，许多人不得不站在小教堂的停车场里。伴随着音乐，一张张克里斯蒂的照片幻灯片播放了10分钟。在特雷西后来与人合著的、关于她女儿的书籍《克里斯蒂》中，
she wrote, We had lots of crazy photos that reflected Christy's passion for life, and it was nice to hear people giggle when they saw some of them. Christy would have really liked that. Investigators responsible for Christy's case were confident that Akshay Chant would be convicted of her murder, as well as the earlier charges relating to her kidnapping and assault. He had confessed to both crimes, and offered detailed accounts of how he had carried them out. A trial was scheduled for October the following year,
她写道：“我们有很多疯狂的照片，它们反映了克里斯蒂对生活的热情，听到人们看到其中一些照片时发出咯咯的笑声，感觉真好。克里斯蒂一定会非常喜欢这样的。”负责克里斯蒂案件的调查人员坚信阿克沙伊·钱特将因谋杀罪以及早前涉及绑架和袭击的指控而被定罪。他对这两起罪行供认不讳，并详细叙述了他是如何实施这些罪行的。审判原定于次年10月进行，
and initially it seemed as though Chant would be pleading not guilty to all four charges. But what looked like an open and shut case took a drastic turn, when news broke that Chant was changing his play. He was now pleading not guilty by reason of insanity. Chant had been examined by mental health experts multiple times since he first attacked Christy. In those meetings he had admitted to feelings of depression and hopelessness, but firmly denied ever experiencing psychotic symptoms, such as seeing hallucinations or hearing voices.
起初，钱特似乎会对所有四项指控都做无罪辩护。然而，这个原本看似板上钉钉的案件却发生了戏剧性的巨变，有消息传出钱特正在更改他的抗辩理由。他现在将以精神失常为由做无罪辩护。自从第一次袭击克里斯蒂以来，钱特曾多次接受精神健康专家的检查。在那些会谈中，他曾承认自己有抑郁和绝望的情绪，但坚决否认曾经历过任何精神病性症状，例如看到幻觉或听到幻听。
Following his killing of Christy, Chant's lawyer had her client assessed by one of the country's leading forensic psychiatrists, Dr David Chaplot. While Dr Chaplot was interviewing Chant, he shared a detail that he hadn't mentioned before. In January 2011, Chant had started hearing a female sounding voice in his head. Sometimes it sounded like humming and singing, but other times the voice spoke words to him. It was clearer in the morning than the evening. Chant first came to know the voice as Lorelei, though he later realized that it actually belonged to a girl who had gone to school with in Wales. She was 8 years old, and her name was Pauline.
在杀害克里斯蒂之后，钱特的律师让其委托人接受了该国顶尖法医精神病学家之一大卫·查普洛博士（Dr David Chaplot）的评估。在查普洛博士对钱特进行讯问时，他透露了一个以前从未提及的细节。2011年1月，钱特开始在脑海中听到一个听起来像是女性的声音。有时它听起来像是在哼唱和唱歌，但其他时候这个声音会对他说出具体的话。这种声音在早晨比晚上更清晰。钱特最初将这个声音称为“洛勒底”（Lorelei），不过他后来意识到，它实际上属于一个曾与他在威尔士一起上过学的女孩。她当时8岁，名叫波琳（Pauline）。
According to Chant, Pauline was the one who'd told him he had to kill Christy Marceau. She'd said that Christy was possessed by the devil. In the days leading up to Christy's death, Pauline's voice became particularly insistent. He tried to resist her instructions, but eventually came to believe he had to obey her. She also started telling Chant that he had to kill two other people, one of whom was Tracy Marceau. He hadn't told anyone else about the voice in his head, especially not the police, as he believed they were out to get him. Dr. Chaplot interviewed Chant a second time, after he'd started taking an antipsychotic medication.
据钱特所说，正是波琳告诉他，他必须杀死克里斯蒂·马索。她曾说克里斯蒂被魔鬼附身了。在克里斯蒂遇害前的几天里，波琳的声音变得异常坚决。他曾试图抗拒她的指令，但最终还是认为自己必须服从她。她还开始对钱特说，他必须杀死另外两个人，其中一人就是特雷西·马索。他没有把脑海里的声音告诉任何人，尤其是警察，因为他相信警察在图谋陷害他。在钱特开始服用抗精神病药物后，查普洛博士对钱特进行了第二次讯问。
This time, he told the doctor, I don't hear the voices anymore. Chant had never demonstrated any remorse for killing Christy, but now he acknowledged that living the rest of his life knowing what he'd done to her would be one of his biggest challenges. Dr. Chaplot considered the possibility that Chant could be faking his symptoms in an attempt to get away with murder. Chant was capable of manipulation, as evident in his past actions to receive bail. But the more he interviewed Chant, the more convinced Dr. Chaplot was that he was telling the truth. If anything, Dr. Chaplot suspected Chant had been lying in the
这一次，他对医生说：“我再也听不到那些声音了。”钱特此前从未对杀害克里斯蒂表现出任何悔意，但现在他承认，余生带着对自己对她所做之事的认知活下去，将是他面临的最大挑战之一。查普洛博士考虑了一种可能性，即钱特可能是在伪装症状，企图逃脱谋杀罪责。钱特具备操控能力，这从他过去为获得保释而采取的行动中可见一斑。但查普洛博士对钱特讯问得越多，就越确信他说的是实话。如果说有什么不同的话，那就是查普洛博士怀疑钱特在
immediate aftermath of killing Christy. He'd claimed to be a cold-hearted murderer, while hiding that he'd been acting on behalf of a voice that he felt spiritually obligated to obey. The various symptoms Chant had been exhibiting for years, like his trouble sleeping, lack of motivation, social withdrawal, and fluctuating weight, were originally seen as symptoms of depression. However, they could also be symptoms of schizophrenia, which Dr. Chaplot believed Chant had. Schizophrenia is a psychiatric illness that typically begins during young adulthood and can cause delusions and hallucinations. Dr. Chaplot also noted that individuals with schizophrenia often experience depression as
杀害克里斯蒂后的immediate（注：原文如此，即“紧接着”）一段时间里一直在说谎。他声称自己是个冷酷无情的杀手，同时却隐瞒了自己是在听从一个他觉得从精神上有义务服从的声音行事。钱特多年来一直表现出的各种症状，比如睡眠困难、缺乏动力、社交退缩以及体重的波动，最初都被视为抑郁症的症状。然而，它们也可能是精神分裂症的症状，查普洛博士认为钱特患有的正是这种病。精神分裂症是一种精神疾病，通常始于成年初期，会导致妄想和幻觉。查普洛博士还指出，精神分裂症患者往往也会经历抑郁症。
well. Once the depression is treated with medication, the schizophrenic symptoms tend to be exposed. Dr. Chaplot concluded that when Chant killed Christy, he was psychotic and completely unaware that he was experiencing auditory hallucinations. Though he knew what he was doing when he killed Christy, the nature of his illness meant he didn't understand that his actions were morally wrong. Dr. Chaplot also believed that Chant hadn't been psychotic during the first attack. He thought it was notable that Chant had changed his mind about raping Christy and let her go. It was likely that his illness was at an earlier stage then and hadn't interfered so severely with his sense of right and wrong.
一旦用药物治愈了抑郁症，精神分裂症的症状往往就会显露出来。查普洛博士得出结论：钱特在杀害克里斯蒂时处于精神病发作状态，完全没有意识到自己正在经历听觉幻觉。尽管他在杀害克里斯蒂时知道自己在做什么，但其疾病的性质意味着他并不理解自己的行为在道德上是错误的。查普洛博士还认为，钱特在第一次袭击时并没有处于精神病发作状态。他认为值得注意的是，钱特当时改变了强奸克里斯蒂的主意并放了她。当时他的病情可能还处于早期阶段，尚未如此严重地干扰他对是非对错的判断力。
Chant's attorney sent Dr. Chaplot's report on to the prosecution, who weren't concerned. It wasn't surprising that the defense would take this kind of approach. They had their own expert assess Chant as well and selected the equally renowned psychiatrist Professor Graham Melsopp. His role was to be more skeptical to make sure Chant wasn't faking his symptoms. Professor Melsopp examined reports and other material from the two separate attacks against Christy Marso. He noticed that at the time of the September assault, Akshay Chant had been very clear about how and why he kidnapped Christy. Nothing he mentioned suggested he was experiencing a psychotic episode. But when he spoke to detectives after killing Christy,
钱特的律师将查普洛博士的报告发给了检方，检方对此并不在意。辩方采取这种方法并不令人意外。他们也有自己的专家对钱特进行评估，并挑选了同样享誉盛名的精神病学家格雷厄姆·梅尔索普教授（Professor Graham Melsopp）。他的职责是保持更多的怀疑态度，以确保钱特没有伪装症状。梅尔索普教授审查了针对克里斯蒂·马索的两起不同袭击事件的报告和其他材料。他注意到，在9月份的袭击发生时，阿克沙伊·钱特对于他是如何以及为何绑架克里斯蒂的，表达得非常清晰。他提及的任何内容都没有表明他当时正在经历精神病发作。但当他在杀害克里斯蒂后与侦探交谈时，
he mentioned a female accomplice who would kill again. He hadn't elaborated on this at the time, but he was referring to Pauline, the voice in his head. Professor Melsopp interviewed Chant. He told the professor the same things that he told Dr. Chaplot. Melsopp noticed that Chant sometimes made up words or used existing ones in strange ways, as though he had his own personal definitions for them. He also made note of Chant's extremely flat effect. Statements from people who knew Chant indicated his thinking had been disordered for some time. He'd been obsessively fixated on capitalism, told various people he was suffering from cervical
他提到了一名会再次杀人的女性同伙。他当时没有详细说明这一点，但他指的就是波琳——他脑海中的那个声音。梅尔索普教授讯问了钱特。他对教授说的话与他对查普洛博士说的一模一样。梅尔索普注意到，钱特有时会杜撰新词，或者以奇怪的方式使用现有的词汇，就好像他为这些词赋予了自己个人的定义一样。他还注意到了钱特极其淡漠的情感反应。认识钱特的人提供的陈述表明，他的思维在一段时间内一直是紊乱的。他一直对资本主义有着强烈的执念，曾对多个人说自己患有宫颈
cancer despite being male, and his conversation was described as sometimes being weird and out of place. All of these were symptoms that were again consistent with schizophrenia. It was noted that Chant's father had battled severe depression as well. There was also a history of mental illness, including schizophrenia on his side of the family. Professor Melsopp came to the same conclusion that Dr. Chaplot had. When Akshay Chant had gone to Christie's house to kill her, he had been legally insane. This was not what the prosecution had wanted to hear. A third and final psychiatrist was consulted just in case, but came back with the exact same finding as the others.
癌（尽管他是男性），而且他的谈话有时被形容为诡异且不合时宜。所有这些症状同样与精神分裂症相吻合。据记录，钱特的父亲也曾与严重的抑郁症作斗争。在他的家族这一侧，也有精神疾病（包括精神分裂症）的病史。梅尔索普教授得出了与查普洛博士相同的结论：当阿克沙伊·钱特去克里斯蒂家杀死她时，他在法律上是精神失常的。这并不是检方想听到的结果。为了以防万一，检方咨询了第三位也是最后一位精神病学家，但得出的结论与其他人完全一致。
With their own experts agreeing that Chant could not be held legally responsible for Christie's murder, there was no way they could go to trial. Crown solicitor Simon Moore had the difficult task of notifying the Marsos. In the months after Christie's death, Tracy had decided to proceed with her move to Adelaide, a move she'd planned to make with her daughter. There were simply too many painful reminders of Christie at home. Simon Moore flew from Auckland to Adelaide so he could notify Tracy and Brian in person. The couple were devastated to hear that Chant would not be going to trial for killing their daughter. They found it incredibly difficult to believe that Chant had been insane at the time. Tracy had
既然他们自己的专家也一致认为钱特无需对克里斯蒂的谋杀承担法律责任，他们就绝无可能出庭受审了。皇家检察官西蒙·穆尔（Simon Moore）面临着一项艰难的任务，那就是将此事通知马索夫妇。在克里斯蒂去世后的几个月里，特雷西决定继续搬往阿德莱德的计划，这是她原本打算和女儿一起完成的搬迁。家里关于克里斯蒂的痛苦回忆实在太多了。西蒙·穆尔从奥克兰飞往阿德莱德，以便亲自将消息告知特雷西和布莱恩。得知钱特不会因杀害他们的女儿而受审，这对夫妇感到痛不欲生。他们极其难以相信钱特在作案时精神失常。特雷西
seen him herself. He'd appeared cold and rational and was able to follow through with a carefully organised plan. It wasn't until they met with Professor Graham Melsopp in person that they began to accept the findings. He explained that it was possible for an individual to carry out pre-planned actions while still suffering from a disease that impacted their moral understanding. Yet, even though the couple came to understand where the experts were coming from, they struggled to agree with them. On September 27, 2012, Akshay Chant pleaded guilty to the charges of kidnapping, assault with intent to commit sexual violation and threatening to do grievous bodily harm.
曾亲眼见过他。他当时显得冷酷而理性，并且能够执行一个精心策划的计划。直到他们亲自与格雷厄姆·梅尔索普教授会面后，他们才开始接受这些调查结果。他解释说，一个人在实施有预谋的行动的同时，完全有可能仍然患有一种影响其道德理解力的疾病。然而，尽管这对夫妇开始理解专家们的出发点，他们却很难予以认同。2012年9月27日，阿克沙伊·钱特对绑架、意图性侵犯而实施袭击以及威胁要造成严重身体伤害的指控表示认罪。
A month later, he was back in Auckland's High Court for his insanity hearing. The experts who had assessed Chant agreed that he should be detained indefinitely as a special patient. Because he'd been able to carry out a brutal killing and had mentioned wanting to harm others, they believed he posed a real danger to public safety. His chances of recovery were considered low, due in part to his young age at the onset of his disease. Just as Helen Wing-Killman ruled that a special patient order would be made for Akshay Chant, he would be detained indefinitely at the Mason Clinic, a secure unit in Auckland that provides forensic mental health services. The only way he will ever be released is if he's found to no
一个月后，他重返奥克兰高等法院出席他的精神失常听证会。评估过钱特的专家们一致认为，他应该作为特殊病人被无限期拘留。由于他能够实施残忍的杀戮并曾表示想要伤害他人，他们认为他对公共安全构成了真实的威胁。由于他发病时的年龄较小等原因，他康复的几率被认为很低。正如海伦·温格-基尔曼法官（Helen Wing-Killman）裁定对阿克沙伊·钱特发出特殊病人令一样，他将被无限期关押在梅森诊所（Mason Clinic）——奥克兰一个提供法医精神健康服务的安全羁押机构。他唯一能获释的途径是被发现
longer be a danger to the public, an extremely unlikely possibility. Justice Wing-Killman also handed down a sentence for the charges relating to Chant's first assault against Christie. Because Christie wasn't able to share her story for herself, her parents had passed along her diary to Justice Wing-Killman. Tracy and Brian had never read it themselves, but they knew Christie had started keeping it after the attack as a way to process her ordeal. Justice Wing-Killman spoke of the insight the diary had offered into Christie's state of mind, telling Chant, Following that kidnapping, it is clear she continued to be afraid of you. She was frightened
不再对公众构成危险，而这种可能性极其渺茫。温格-基尔曼法官还对涉及钱特首次袭击克里斯蒂的指控作出了宣判。由于克里斯蒂无法亲自讲述她的故事，她的父母将她的日记交给了温格-基尔曼法官。特雷西和布莱恩从未自己读过这本日记，但他们知道克里斯蒂是在袭击发生后开始记日记的，以此来处理她所遭受的磨难。温格-基尔曼法官谈到了这本日记对克里斯蒂心路历程所提供的深刻见解，她对钱特说道：“在那次绑架之后，很显然，她继续对你感到恐惧。她害怕
that you would return to harm her family, and that fear only increased on your release. Her journal also makes clear that she regarded her life as having been fundamentally changed by what you did to her. Justice Wing-Killman then sentenced Chant to three years for kidnapping, two years for assault with intent to sexually violate, and one year for threatening to do grievous bodily harm. He would also serve these years at the Mason Clinic. Outside the courthouse, Tracy and Brian Marso addressed the media. Brian fought back tears, as he said. For us, no sentence will ever be sufficient for the loss of Christie. It will never bring her back, or even make us feel that justice has actually been done.
你会回来伤害她的家人，而这种恐惧在她获释后只增不减。她的日记也清楚地表明，她认为自己的人生被你对她所做的事情彻底改变了。”随后，温格-基尔曼法官判处钱特因绑架罪获刑三年、因意图性侵犯袭击罪获刑两年、因威胁造成严重身体伤害罪获刑一年。这些刑期也将在梅森诊所服刑。法院外，特雷西和布莱恩·马索向媒体发表了讲话。布莱恩强忍着泪水说道：“对我们而言，任何判决都永远无法弥补克里斯蒂的损失。这永远无法让她死而复生，甚至无法让我们觉得正义真正得到了伸张。”
For us, he will always be Christie's murderer. And in our eyes, he will always be guilty. As well as viewing Chant as Christie's murderer, the Marso's couldn't help but blame someone else for their daughter's death. They couldn't comprehend why Judge David McNaughton had approved Chant's bail application against the wishes of the police, their family, and Christie herself. If Chant had been kept in custody following his first violent assault, then he never would have been able to harm Christie again. Much of the New Zealand public shared their concerns. News articles honed in on the fact that Chant had been bailed to a residence just 350 metres from Christie's home,
“对我们而言，他永远都是克里斯蒂的杀人凶手。在我们的眼中，他永远都是有罪的。”除了视钱特为克里斯蒂的杀人凶手外，马索夫妇也不禁将女儿的死归咎于其他人。他们无法理解，为什么大卫·麦克诺顿法官会在违背警察、他们的家庭以及克里斯蒂本人意愿的情况下，批准钱特的保释申请。如果钱特在第一次暴力袭击后被收押，那么他根本就没机会再次伤害克里斯蒂了。新西兰公众中有很大一部分人也持相同的担忧。新闻报道聚焦于这样一个事实：钱特被保释到的住所距离克里斯蒂的家仅350米，
despite saying he wanted revenge against her. An organisation called the Sensible Sentencing Trust got in touch with the Marso family and helped them campaign to have bail laws amended. This led to the Bail Amendment Act being passed into New Zealand law in 2013. This new act put the onus on defendants to prove they weren't a threat to the community, rather than having the police argue the opposite. In June 2017, almost six years after Akshay Chant killed Christie Marso, an inquest was held into her death to explore the circumstances that resulted in Chant being granted bail. Judge David McNaughton, who has never spoken publicly about his decision,
尽管他曾说过想要对她进行报复。一个名为“明智量刑信托”（Sensible Sentencing Trust）的组织与马索家族取得了联系，并协助他们发起运动，推动修改保释法律。这促成了《2013年保释修正案》在新西兰法律中的通过。这项新法律将举证责任交给了被告，由他们来证明自己对社区不构成威胁，而不是由警察去争辩相反的情况。2017年6月，在阿克沙伊·钱特杀害克里斯蒂·马索近六年之后，就她的死因举行了一场研讯，以调查导致钱特获得保释的情况。大卫·麦克诺顿法官从未公开谈论过他的这一决定，
did not appear as a witness. This was due to New Zealand law preventing judges from being called to give evidence. The inquest took place over 13 days. The coroner handed down a 127-page report in March of the following year. She found that Christie was let down by multiple systemic failures and a lack of collaboration between various departments and agencies. Judge Barbara Morris, the first judge to hear Chant's bail application, had requested that an electronic monitoring assessment be completed for Chant. This involves a suspect being fitted with a GPS monitor, so there were abouts attract at all times. But neither the police prosecutors nor the defense followed up on this request.
他并未作为证人出庭。这是因为新西兰法律禁止传唤法官出庭作证。本次研讯历时13天。死因研讯官在次年3月发布了一份长达127页的报告。她发现克里斯蒂遭到了一系列系统性失误以及各个部门和机构之间缺乏合作的辜负。巴尔芭拉·莫里斯法官作为首位审理钱特保释申请的法官，曾要求对钱特进行电子监控评估。这涉及为嫌疑人佩戴GPS监控器，以便随时追踪其行踪。但警方检察官和辩方都没有跟进这一请求。
Judge Morris had denied bail partially because of how close Chant's home was to Christie's. But Judge David McNaughton had not been told how close the two addresses were to each other. The police prosecutor who attended Chant's second bail hearing had that information, but did not share it with the judge because she felt he was uninterested in police concerns and didn't give her an opportunity to speak. From her point of view, he had already made his mind up in favour of granting bail. Judge McNaughton was also under the impression that Chant's mother, Suchita, his sister, or his aunt would stay with him at all times. Chant's lawyer had mistakenly identified his sister as a university student,
莫里斯法官部分是因为钱特的家离克里斯蒂的家太近而拒绝了保释。但大卫·麦克诺顿法官并未被告知这两个地址彼此相距多近。出席钱特第二次保释听证会的警方检察官掌握了这一信息，但并未将其分享给法官，因为她觉得法官对警方的关切不感兴趣，也没有给她发言的机会。在她看来，法官当时已经下定决心要批准保释。麦克诺顿法官还误以为钱特的母亲苏奇塔、他的妹妹或他的阿姨会全天候陪着他。钱特的律师错误地将他的妹妹识别为大学生，
when she was actually a juvenile who was still at school, too young to take on such a role. Judge McNaughton didn't know that Suchita had consistent work commitments, and that his aunt needed to be at home with her own child before school hours. Chant's family said that they had not been told that constant supervision was expected of them. The coroner also found that Chant's initial mental health reviews had been rushed and failed to provide a proper risk assessment. In total, she gave 10 recommendations to the Ministry of Justice, Department of Corrections, the police, and Wighter-Mattard District Health Board in the hopes of preventing a similar tragedy in the future.
而实际上她只是一名仍在上学的未成年人，年龄太小，无法承担这样的角色。麦克诺顿法官并不知道苏奇塔有稳定的工作安排，也不知道他的阿姨在上学时间之前需要在家照顾自己的孩子。钱特的家属表示，没有人告诉他们需要对其实施持续监督。死因研讯官还发现，钱特最初的精神健康评估过于仓促，未能提供恰当的风险评估。总共，她向司法部、惩教部、警方以及Waitemata地区卫生局提出了10项建议，希望借此防止未来发生类似的悲剧。
Tracy and Brian Marso welcomed the coroner's findings and said the inquest had revealed to them how Christie had been failed in multiple ways. In an interview with Anna Leiske of the New Zealand Herald, Tracy said, There was more than one hand on the knife that day. We're extremely grateful that the coroner's taken this so seriously. Finally, someone's on Christie's side. In a letter she wrote to Christie one year after her death, Tracy revealed that she cried herself to sleep most nights, thinking that she had failed her daughter. Christie's father Brian has also grappled with guilt due to being overseas when his daughter was first kidnapped and later killed. He had considered leaving his job in Australia,
特雷西和布莱恩·马索对死因研讯官的调查结果表示欢迎，并称这场研讯向他们揭示了克里斯蒂是如何在多个方面遭到辜负的。在接受《新西兰先驱报》安娜·里斯克（Anna Leisk）的采访时，特雷西说：“那天握着刀的手不止一只。我们非常感谢死因研讯官能如此严肃地对待此事。终于有人站在克里斯蒂这一边了。”在克里斯蒂去世一年后写给她的一封信中，特雷西透露，她几乎每天夜里都哭着入睡，认为自己辜负了女儿。克里斯蒂的父亲布莱恩也一直饱受内疚之苦，因为在女儿首次被绑架以及后来被杀时，他身在海外。他曾考虑辞去澳大利亚的工作，
but police had reassured him that Christie would be safe and his family needed the income. In November 2012, the Marso's set up a legacy in their daughter's name, the Christie Marso Charitable Trust. Through fundraising and donations, the trust provides annual scholarships for teenagers to attend a course through Outward Bound. Christie had dreamed of completing one of the organization's outdoor challenge courses, but never had the chance to do so. Tracy, Brian and Christie's sister Heather have all gotten matching tattoos of Christie on their shoulders. As they told journalist Anna Leisk, these symbolize how Christie is always watching their backs. Anna Leisk first interviewed the Marso's just a few months after Christie's
但警方曾向他保证克里斯蒂会很安全，而且他的家庭需要这笔收入。2012年11月，马索夫妇以他们女儿的名字设立了一个遗赠基金——克里斯蒂·马索慈善信托基金（The Christie Marceau Charitable Trust）。通过筹款和捐赠，该信托基金每年为青少年提供奖学金，让他们参加“外展训练”（Outward Bound）课程。克里斯蒂曾梦想完成该组织的一个户外挑战课程，但从未有机会这样做。特雷西、布莱恩以及克里斯蒂的妹妹希瑟都在肩膀上纹了克里斯蒂的同款纹身。正如他们对记者安娜·里斯克所说的那样，这些纹身象征着克里斯蒂一直在守护着他们。安娜·里斯克在克里斯蒂去世几个月后首次采访了马索夫妇，
death and formed a strong friendship with them over the following year. She later collaborated with Tracy on a book titled Christie, a family's tragic loss and a mother's fight for justice. For Tracy, the book was a way to immortalize her daughter and tell her story. Tracy's portion of the book concludes with a letter addressed to Christie that ends with the words. The only way I can try to make sense of it is to believe that you were a special person only lent to Worth for a short time to make change and spread good. As much as it is agony that we lost you so soon, I am so glad we were chosen to be your parents because you brought so much joy to us and I learned so much from your beautiful kindness.
并在接下来的的一年里与他们结下了深厚的友谊。她后来与特雷西合作撰写了一本书，名为《克里斯蒂：一个家庭的悲惨失落与一位母亲对正义的抗争》（Christie: A family's tragic loss and a mother's fight for justice）。对特雷西而言，这本书是永纪女儿并讲述她故事的一种方式。书中属于特雷西的部分以一封写给克里斯蒂的信结尾，信的最后写道：“我试图理解这一切的唯一方式，就是相信你是一个特殊的人，只是被借给这个世界很短的一段时间，来带去改变、传播美好。尽管我们这么快就失去你令我感到万分痛苦，但我无比庆幸我们被选中成为你的父母，因为你给我们带来了那么多的快乐，我也从你的美丽善良中学到了那么多。”
I will love you to the end of time and I will use the rest of my time to continue helping people in your name. I know you will be proud of that. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“我会爱你到地老天荒，我将用余下的时间继续以你的名义帮助他人。我知道你会为此感到骄傲的。”该剧集目前尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。